tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel raymond
barre à la télévision ouverture du
dialogue social et confirmations de
l'impôt georges séguy propos d'un front
syndical contre cet impôt sur la
sécheresse refus de la cfdt et de force
ouvrière affaires d'assaut
l'extravagante disparition d'un
comptable au dessus de tout soupçon
viking de atterrissage dans quelques
heures
bonsoir le ciel est gris
la mer est agitée laisse un peu la
fenêtre fermée
on peut même prévoir un feu de bois
quand c'est possible c'est un climat
tout à fait propice pour s'enfermer avec
les factures non réglées pendant l'été
le loyer les assurances le crédit
profitons-en
et puis les impôts mettons de côté les
10% ne sait jamais ce week-end va se va
prolonger les grandes vacances d'une
autre façon c'est vrai qu'on a encore un
mois pour connaître le montant exact de
la facture de la sécheresse puis de
l'inflation la semaine qui s'achève a
été marquée par deux temps forts
monsieur bart a commencé à travailler
poussé par le besoin de confiance des
français pour réparer les déséquilibres
et faire que l'économie s'emballe -
monsieur bart laisse entendre et tout le
monde le comprenez que ça ne va pas si
mal en france mais qu'il ya ce fameux
fléau de l'inflation qu'il faut
maîtriser tout le monde était d'accord
sauf sur les méthodes et puis il ya eu
la facture de la sécheresse et là ça n'a
plus été du tout deuxième temps fort de
la semaine hier et aujourd'hui
l'opposition de gauche les syndicats et
les mouvements agricoles des mouvements
agricoles plutôt sont déjà en révolte
contre le recours un impôt qui doit
indemniser des vraies victimes de la
sécheresse encore faut-il savoir où
elles sont et le citoyen moyen lui
s'interroge en maugréant même s'il admet
la nécessité de la solidarité nationale
c'est dans ce climat que le premier
ministre répondant aux questions
d'emmanuel de la taille et jean marie
cavada a précisé
thaler l'esprit dans lequel il va
commencer la semaine prochaine son
dialogue avec tous les partenaires
sociaux écoutez je crois que la france
est un pays de société libérale et une
société pluraliste dans une telle
société
il faut qu'existe un dialogue social un
dialogue entre les partenaires sociaux
un dialogue entre les partenaires
sociaux et le gouvernement
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
recevrai pendant toute la semaine
prochaine toutes les organisations
professionnelles
je voudrais à ce sujet a indiqué que si
je suis partisan du dialogue l'estiment
qui ne fera qu il ait une conclusion des
responsables les organisations
professionnelles sont chargés de
défendre de façon très légitime
d'ailleurs les intérêts de leur mandat
l'état lui est en charge de l'intérêt
général et après une information
après une discussion
loyal est clair le gouvernement arrêtera
la politique économique et financière
qui permettra de lutter contre
l'inflation
cette politique j'espère qu'elle sera
une politique de clarté et de justice
nous imposer ministre avant de recevoir
parmi les partenaires sociaux notamment
les syndicats la semaine prochaine on a
déjà deux puis à midi par la parole de
par la bouche de mes yeux c'est guy pour
la cgt incertain avant goût de ce que
peut être cette conversation sept
centrales syndicales appellent à une
sorte de mobilisation générale
nous verrons ce que ça donnera avec les
autres partenaires syndicaux quelle est
votre opinion à ce sujet et comment
réagissez vous à ce commentaire
mon opinion je les exprime de la manière
que je joue je
il exprimait la vôtre nous verrons bien
et en ce qui concerne l'impôt sécheresse
est ce que vous maintenez le principe de
cet impôt est qu'est-ce que je n'ai pas
essayé de l'élargir dans un plan
d'ensemble de façon à ce que les
agriculteurs n'ai pas l'impression qu'on
va braquer les salariés contre oui les
agriculteurs ont été frappés par une
calamité nationale normale par
conséquent qu'il y est un effort de
solidarité nationale à leur égard je
vous rappelle que 7 au mois de juin
dernier que le président de la
république a dit que le revenu des
agriculteurs pour 1976 ne devrait pas
être inférieur à celui et qu'ils avaient
obtenu en 1975 au mois d'août le 25 août
le gouvernement a décidé décède à valoir
sur les aides définitives qui seront
accordés après le conseil des ministres
du 29 septembre
il est nécessaire en effet d'attendre
qu'un bilans soient dressés et à partir
de là nous fixerons le montant et la
répartition de l'effort définitif mais
la france est dans une situation
inflationniste
par conséquent l'effort de solidarité
nationale doit être effectué dans des
conditions qui
n'aggrave pas la situation des finances
publiques
il est donc normal que l'on ait recours
à l'impôt je sais que certains
préconisent un recours à l'emprunt
j'ai le sentiment que c'est une forme
assez subtil d'égoïsme ça veut dire
qu'il n'y en a pas de recours à
l'emprunt
il n'y aura pas de recours à l'emprunt
pour une raison très simple c'est que
recourir à l'emprunt signifie que l'on
transférait sur les générations futures
la charge de l'effort national qui doit
être accompli et je voudrais ajouter si
vous permettez et sur un point et une
réponse à la question posée par monsieur
de la taille
le collectif budgétaire qui interviendra
le 29 septembre doit assurer l'équilibré
des finances publiques et les aides qui
seront accordées aux agriculteurs se
sont un élément seulement de l'effort
qui doit être accompli pour que nos
finances publiques restent équilibrés ce
qui veut dire monsieur paris-nice
qu'éventuellement cet impôt dont il
reste à définir la hauteur la gamme
c'est un peu pourrait servir non
seulement à la solidarité sécheresse
mais par exemple à d'autres calamités
kick soufrière bien à équilibrer le
budget mais vous avez vu que le décret
d'avant ce qui a été signé il ya
quelques jours et vise non seulement les
aides apportées aux agriculteurs mais
également les frais qui sont liées à
aux conséquences de l'éruption du volcan
de la soufrière
dans ces conditions de scène premier
ministre qu'est ce qu'elle voulait dire
le ministre l'agriculture monsieur
bonnet hier en parlant d' impôt sur les
personnes morales faudrait-il s'agit par
exemple d'un impôt sur le capital
je ne crois pas qu'il faille pour le
moment parler de diverses méthodes pour
la raison bien simple que nous ne
connaissons pas le montant définitif de
l'aide apportée et le gouvernement n'a
pas délibéré des conditions dans
lesquelles le recours à l'impôt
s'effectuerait je considère par
conséquent que tout ce qui peut être dit
à l'heure actuelle ne repose pas sur une
information fondée
j'ai le premier ministre vous avez fait
un démarrage tambour battant ce séguy a
parlé de zorro est ce que vous pensez
pas qu l'attend maintenant des mesures
jouent contre eux depuis ma l'agitation
avant les mesures le chef de l'état si
j'étais zorro peut-être suis-je plutôt
bernardo je suis un grand amateur des
films de zorro en excuses on dit que le
capital de confiance dont je dispose est
à cet égard je voudrais remercier les
françaises et les français qui m'ont
écrit il ne me connaissait pas mais qui
nous écrit des lettres forte
encourageantes
ceci dit il n'y a pas le feu dans la
maison
la politique contre l'inflation a déjà
été entreprise
elle doit être poursuivie et elle doit
être amplifiée et il n'y a aucune raison
de draps de dramatiser la situation
actuelle la situation est préoccupante
je ne veux pas dit
qu'il faille considérer avec une
certaine sérénité et problèmes que nous
aurons à résoudre à la fin de cette
année et l'an prochain mais est
néanmoins il faut éviter toute
précipitation
de surcroît une positif économique et
financière fut-elle élaboré par le
premier ministre qui assume en même
temps les fonctions de ministre de
l'économie et des finances n'est pas
l'oeuvre d'un seul homme
elle est l'oeuvre d'un gouvernement par
conséquent il est normal que le
gouvernement délibère et là était
entendu que la délibération aura lieu le
22 septembre
de telle sorte que les mesures qui
interviendront dans la loi de finances
pour 1977 soit présenté au parlement à
ce moment là enfin je souhaitais avant
d'arrêter les mesures
je proposerai au gouvernement recevoir
les organisations syndicales
que n'aurait-on pas dit si j'avais fait
sortir des mesures comme un lapin d'un
chapeau et si je ne mettais pas entouré
d'avis de suggestions et de conseil ce
que je voudrais dire aux françaises et
aux français c'est que je crois que la
politique du gouvernement doit être
conduite en dehors de toute agitation le
premier ministre dans un certain nombre
de démocraties anglo saxon quand il ya
crise de situations d'austérité grave on
va le chef de gouvernement
consulter ou en tout cas entendre les
chefs de l'opposition est ce que vous
seriez prêt à adopter la même procédure
je crois que depuis de nombreux mois
déjà
le président de la république a dit
qu'il était tout prêt à recevoir les
chefs de l'opposition
en ce qui me concerne ma porte est
ouverte
le point de formuler une habitation je
n'ai pas formulé d'invitation ceux qui
désirent me voir sont toujours
sûr que je m'arrangerai pour les
rencontrer voilà je crois que le premier
ministre a été très clair sur ses
intentions et aussi sur le sur les
modalités sur sur le fait que rien n'est
décidé encore sur les modalités de
l'impôt sécheresse
pourtant il ya sûrement pour vous un
point qui reste dans l'ombre
bernardo késako quand monsieur bart a
été nommé au gouvernement je georges
séguy que vous entendrez tout à l'heure
sur son imposition à l'impôt sécheresse
georges séguy a dit quand il a appris la
nomination de monsieur bart ça y est
zorro est arrivé
on veut faire croire au pays qu'il va
tout arranger avec sa science des
problèmes économiques
d'où la question des manuels de la
taille et la réponse de monsieur bart je
ne suis pas zorro
je serais plutôt bernardo bernardo c'est
le serviteur est plus que le serviteur
muet et fidèle 2 euros celui qui prépare
les coûts le cheval à la rigueur le
fouet 2 euros bref aujourd'hui le
serviteur de l'état
je cela dit je ne pense pas que monsieur
bart doivent s'excuser d'être un amateur
de zorro nous le sommes tous un peu
alors revenons maintenant à georges
séguy après le bureau du parti
communiste y hier qu'ils appelaient des
partis de gauche à la concertation
contre le super impôts giscardien pour
indemniser la sécheresse georges séguy
de la cgt a proposé à toutes les
organisations syndicales représentatives
une rencontre pour une riposte massive
georges séguy proposait une action des
syndicats qui n'ont pas souvent
l'habitude d'agir ensemble une action
unitaire de la cgt aux cadres en passant
par force ouvrière la cfdt et la cftc
est d'ores et déjà on sait que plusieurs
syndicats repousseront l'initiative de
la cgt ainsi force ouvrière a dit non
les cadres de la cgc s'apprêterait à en
faire autant et la cfdt qui veut bien
discuter des problèmes fiscaux avec la
cgt ne serait selon ses propres termes
accepté de participer à un simple front
du refus de l'impôt vous allez entendre
comment georges séguy à formuler son
appel ce matin
et puis emmanuel de la taille fera
ensuite le point sur ce début de
l'épreuve de force à propos de l'impôt
sécheresse
nous proposons à toutes les autres
organisations syndicales ouvriers et
nous faisons aussi des propositions dans
cet esprit à celles des agriculteurs de
telle manière que l'ensemble réagissez
protestent et oblige le gouvernement à
renoncer à cette décision pour prendre
des mesures correspondantes aux intérêts
de toute la population qui produit les
richesses nationales à la ville ou à la
campagne
ça signifie une action d'ampleur
national importante sur laquelle je ne
peux pas anticiper puisqu'elle ira
discuter avec nos partenaires mais ça ne
sera pas un baroud d'honneur
nous comprenons parfaitement et nous
sommes pour le vaste effort de
solidarité nationale qui s'imposent pour
venir en aide aux agriculteurs dans
l'intérêt même du pays mais nous
n'acceptons pas que ce soit les salariés
qui fassent les frais de ce financement
ravir les plus frappés par les impôts
par la hausse des prix par le chômage
nous préconisons d'autres solutions et
en particulier la taxation des profits
des grands trusts agroalimentaires la
taxation des supers bénéfices faits par
les spéculateurs sur le dos de la
collectivité nationale et au péril du
franc et enfin l'intervention du fonds
prévu à cet effet au sein du marché
commun et l'état doit payer en diminuant
quelques dépenses improductives ils
utilisent avant de commencer son
dialogue social à raymond barre voit
donc se lever une sorte de rébellion
généralisée contre l'impôt sécheresse
bien sûr il est souvent si difficile de
réaliser un front syndical qu'un plan de
redressement mais cela montre bien un
phénomène clé c'est que si l'inflation
est souvent un moyen facile pour
camoufler les contradictions sociales on
bute immédiatement sur les inégalités
dès lors que l'on veut s'attaquer à
l'inflation
en effet le financement de la sécheresse
est un choix fondamental sur l'inflation
en gros il n'y a que trois moyens sans
compter les limonadiers les super prof
déficit budgétaire et planche à billets
c'est sans douleur mais inflationnistes
l'emprunt mais on charge les budgets
suivants ne rembourse et enfin
l'augmentation des infos qui
naturellement fait tempêté les salariés
les cadres et inquiète les agriculteurs
qui ont peur que l'on dresse les
travailleurs contre les paysans
toute cette agitation illustre bien les
deux versants de l'inflation primo c'est
à moyens temporaires de financer la paix
sociale il suffit que l'état miracle
finances par la planche à billets toutes
les revendications sans rien prendre aux
autres et on retrouve la note dans
l'inflation est un excellent indicateur
des tensions sociales
secundo quand on s'attaque à l'inflation
on voit immédiatement pour sauter au
visage
les inégalités et les antagonismes entre
les catégories sociales ce qui fait dire
à françois mitterrand que seule la
gauche pourrait bénéficier du consensus
social nécessaire raymond barre devra
donc compenser ces mesures d'austérité
par des actions de justice sur les
inégalités et aussi sur les privilèges
c'est sans doute la première chose que
lui demanderont et syndic un fait
important aujourd'hui également pour
l'action concertée de la majorité
olivier guichard le numéro deux au
gouvernement dans l'ordre hiérarchique
avec le label eu des airs je veux redire
je devrais dire de gaulliste olivier
guichard a été chargé par le premier
ministre de former un groupe de travail
au sein du gouvernement avec les
représentants des autres grandes
tendances de la majorité michel
poniatowski pour les républicains
indépendants jean lecanuet pour les
centristes
michel durafour pour les radicaux
majorité ce groupe aura pour tâche de
fixer les modalités de l'action commune
que doivent mener les formations
politiques qui soutiennent l'action du
président de la république il n'est plus
question vous le voyez comme avec
jacques chirac de coordonner la majorité
c'est un mot qui a disparu mais c'est
toujours la cohésion et l'efficacité que
l'on recherche pour les municipales de
77 et surtout les législatives de 78 qui
engageront l'avenir du pays
ce sont les termes de la lettre du
premier ministre aux différents courants
de la majorité lettre qui leur a été
communiquée au cours du déjeuner qui a
réuni les leaders de ces courants à
l'hôtel matignon
monsieur bart dit qu'avec ses
responsabilités économiques et
financières à lui il ne pourra pas
accorder le temps nécessaire à la
préparation de ces deux élections et
c'est pourquoi ils chargent olivier
guichard de présider le groupe de
travail son secrétaire d'état monsieur
ruffenach suivra les travaux du groupe
il n'y a donc plus de coordonnateur de
la majorité mais un groupe de travail
présidé par un du dr c'est vrai mais qui
n'est pas premier ministre et ce détail
qui compte peut parfaitement réduire les
blocages psychologiques qui existait
auparavant
mais les forces en présence restent les
mêmes dans la majorité avec cette
intention avouée de part et d'autre de
ne pas se laisser marcher sur les pieds
par les partenaires la disparition d'un
homme peut passer inaperçue même si
c'est un cadre de première grandeur
c'était bien le cas d'hervé vater dont
le nom n'était pas célèbre mais dont la
raison sociale pour laquelle il
travaillait il était infiniment
puisqu'il s'agit des entreprises marcel
dassault
il y travaillait depuis un quart de
siècle il était un des hommes de
confiance de marcel dassault
la disparition d'un tel homme pourrait
ne pas être public
on sait s'arranger dans l'est dans le
monde des affaires pour expliquer
l'absence d'un collaborateur fut-il le
plus précieux mais quand un homme
disparaît avec 8 millions de francs
c'est une autre affaire il faut prévenir
la police c'est ce qu'on a fait il ya
deux mois
il faut rechercher l'argent et l'homme
on pense qu'on ne retrouvera pas
l'argent maintenant mais il faudra au
moins que l'homme s'explique même s'il
semble et c'est assez curieux que
presque tout le monde lui ai pardonné
son employeur moteur notamment et la
police qui n'a pas contrairement à ce
qu'on a dit délivré de mandat d'arrêt
international contre lui qui s'est
simplement informer auprès d'interpol
d'un séjour éventuelle à l'étranger
d'hervé de vathaire hervé de vathaire
disparu dans des conditions extrêmement
mystérieuse ferait sans doute le sans
aucun doute le héros d'un best-seller
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on dit
toujours bien sûr quand on a affaire un
personnage aussi bien intégré à la haute
société qui devient tout à coup un héros
mystérieux de l'actualité et l'actualité
aujourd'hui avec ce personnage central
d'hervé de vathaire accompagné de jean
qu'est cette sorte d'arsène lupin pour
le tiers-monde
c'est un roman qui aurait pu être écrit
tout à la fois par paul guimard romain
gary et gérard de villiers avec vous
savez le ras-le-bol du quinquagénaire
le chagrin personnel une intrigue
international des dossiers fantôme est
en tout cas ce qui est concret une
disparition d'un homme est de 8 millions
de francs robert werner vous raconte
l'histoire de cette double disparition
qui défraie la chronique aujourd'hui peu
avant sa disparition
hervé de vathaire se présentent à la
banque de son patron avenue de la grande
armée
il veut retirer huit millions de francs
800 millions anciens hervé de batteur on
le connaît bien à la banque c'est le
comptable de monsieur dassault millions
c'est beaucoup d'argent mais on dit à
monsieur de batteur qu'est la signature
du patron tenez nous un petit délai une
heure deux heures plus tard le comptable
revient on lui remet l'argent en
coupures de 500 francs et à la banque on
donne un petit coup de téléphone tout de
même chez marcel dassault et là on
apprend que monsieur de vathaire ne
devait rien retirer du tout quelle
émotion
c'est ici passage de vie d'aucun témoin
apercevra le comptable le connaît et il
le trouve extrêmement préoccupé sombre
et très pressés ne le reverra plus il ne
reparaît pas à son domicile parisien ni
dans sa propriété de beaulaincourt dans
l'oise mais voyant français policiers
tout d'abord s'il a cette fortune en
poche ces 800 millions
et bien c'est justement pour disparaître
les policiers comprendront bien vite que
ce n'est pas si simple
tout d'abord qui est hervé de vathaire
marié depuis 23 ans père de deux
jumelles qui ont aujourd'hui 22 ans un
bourgeois bon tu as une petite
cinquantaine blond taille moyenne ici
d'une famille bourguignonne soigner
correct servant marcel dassault
depuis 25 ans il n'est pas aussi
important qu'on le dit mme a expliqué
gerald de bénouville amis de marcel
dassault responsable de ventes d'avions
pour l'atlantique chargé de financement
à long terme du programme mercury
maintenant les pouces d'hervé de
vathaire a été très longtemps malade et
un matin lorsqu'il remonte chez lui à
paris
il a trouvé mort dans sa baignoire
c'était le noyer s'agit-il d'un accident
est ce un suicide de batteur qui s'est
montré un époux très attentifs change à
partir de ce jour quelque temps après
une amie lui présentera l'étrange
enquête qui demeure à boulogne ici
chantier dont on a tant parlé c'est
exactement son contraire désorienté se
sentant seul le comptable et coûte
peut-être trop les propos enflammés de
jean kaki plus que jamais raid aventure
je me définis comme comme un homme
d'action c'est à dire un homme
d'efficacité avant tout je fais partie
d'aucun mouvement politique
et d'aucune association homme d'action
vous l'avez entendu c'est ainsi que
j'encaisse se définit un mercenaire au
grand coeur pur but remet pas gangster
disent la plupart de ceux qui l'ont
côtoyé à 34 ans gens qui collectionnent
les actions rocambolesque qu'ils ont
déjà conduit aux quatre coins du monde
après l'algérie dans les rangs de l'oes
ce sera le yémen le biafra et puis le
liban avec les phalangistes mais c'est
en 1971 qu'il fera le plus parler de lui
en détournant un avion de la
pakistanaise line sur l'aéroport d'orly
il réclame 20 tonnes de médicaments pour
le bangladesh à son procès andré malraux
dira de lui c'est un homme courageux qui
s'est conduit noblement mater a pu
constituer un dossier photographique des
opérations financières dont il a été le
témoin
j'enquête connaissait-il l'existence de
ce dossier eh bien il demandait de lui
communiquer en juin dernier
le comptable est très inquiet il donne
un coup de téléphone à sa famille alors
qu'il a déjà disparu
edit j'ai dû partir pour semer ce qui me
traquent et il la victime d'un chantage
internationale peut-on compromettre la
firme d'assaut les imaginations vont
tous azimuts et aujourd'hui on n'est sûr
de rien si une chose
j'enquête en tout cas l'âme de cette
affaire mais il a disparu lui aussi
marcel dassault pourtant délesté de huy
lyon a retiré sa plainte pour la famille
dit il c'était un chef de service
remarquable mais depuis la mort étrange
de sa femme hervé de vathaire n'était
plus le même homme
maintenant jean-louis burgat cette
affaire extrêmement compliqué et nous
amène quand même poser la première
question à votre virvée de materis il
encore vivant et coûtait rien dans
l'état actuel de l'enquêté ne permet de
parler de mort d'assassinât ou de
suicide je vous dirais même que les
enquêteurs estiment comme monsieur de
vathaire devrait se manifester au tout
art maintenant son affaire et dans le
domaine public toute la personnalité de
l'homme ses antécédents sa carrière
porte à croire qu'il n'a pas retiré les
huit millions pour son propre compte
ensuite comment imaginer qu'un homme qui
jouissait d'une situation plus que
confortable qui venait de refaire sa vie
avec une jeune et jolie femme ait décidé
de tout abandonner pour courir le monde
écoutez ce que disait ce matin des
collaborateurs de marcel dassault à
robert werner
s'agit du général de bénouville
cet homme est un homme intelligent
compétent dans son métier discret et qui
a travaillé pendant 23 ans
honnêtement dans cette maison si bien
que tant qu'on n'a pas la preuve de sa
culpabilité
on peut pas oublier 23 ans de bons
services tout à coup pour l'accusé est
parti avec de l'argent lui a pardonné
par ses frères blanc c'est fait c'est la
sphère de la police selon vous pourquoi
avez vous une petite idée
je n'ai aucune idée aucune idée je sais
qu'il a pris cet argent qu'il n'aurait
pas dû prendre et je sais que avant de
le condamner
nous avons voulu comprendre s'il n'avait
pas été l'instrument de quelqu'un
d'autre ça nous paraît improbable qu'un
homme qui a toujours été honnête
un bon matin se révèle un voleur bon et
puis il ya ce fameux dossier de
photocopies sur les comptes financiers
des entreprises d'assaut établi par
hervé de vathaire lui même et la commune
avec la communication qui ont été faites
ensuite agent qu'est les menaces qui ont
été faites autour de ce dossier alors la
queue qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on en
pense mais bien là pour les policiers
une chose est certaine en tout cas c'est
que jean quel est le personnage central
de la faire première hypothèse donc
l'employé modèle le comptable sans
reproche et séduit par le baroudeur qui
a décidé depuis longtemps d'assainir la
société de vathaire parle de son travail
puis de la société dassault enfin du
commerce des armes ils se confient
tellement qu'il en arrive à présenter la
photocopie de certains dossiers qui lui
passe entre les mains pour la plupart de
ces dossiers sont des des factures des
chiffres mais de très gros chiffres
j'encaisse et dans son personnage est
scandalisé il trouve tout cela infâme il
conserve les dossiers et décide
finalement de jouer les redresseurs de
torts pour cela il n'y a pas 36
solutions pour pénaliser la société
dassault il extorque 8 millions à son
ancien ami contre la restitution des
dossiers c'est une hypothèse retenue par
une personne très proche de jean quai
kim a même affirmé par téléphone il ya
un instant que les 800 millions seraient
partis aider certains sinistrés au liban
ce serait presque une une trop belle
histoire
l'autre hypothèse est moins merveilleuse
au moment où les pots-de-vin de look et
découvre
bouh bon nombre de commerçants d'armes
on peut imaginer une affaire montée pour
compromettre le groupe dassault qui est
en mesure d'emporter bientôt
d'importants contrats gens qu'est qui
fréquentent toujours le milieu des
mercenaires internationaux auraient pu
montrer imprudemment à des personnages
douteux les dossiers de vathaire le
comptable déjà secoué par le décès
récent de sa femme aurait cédé sous la
menace de mort portées contre ses deux
filles il en avait parlé de cette menace
a des amis il ya quelques mois et pour
fuir avec jean qu'est il aurait empoché
les 8 millions mais peut-être aura-t-on
d'autres surprises si demain hervé de
vathaire décide de revenir à l'air libre
maintenant on sait que la planète mars
et rouge que son sol ressemble à s'y
méprendre au désert de l'arizona qui
fait au moins 4 qu'il y fait moins 85 la
nuit et -6 à midi
on sait également grâce aux analyses
effectuées par l'engin vikings vikings
numéro un
l'engin vikings américain numéro un que
la hoya dans la poussière martienne
quelque chose qui respire qu'ils mangent
et qui assimile et ce quelque chose
quand on le cherche
eh bien on ne trouve pas vous m'avez
compris il s'agit des hypothétiques
petits martiens et bien pour lever le
doute peut-être pour tenter d'en savoir
plus en tout cas les américains ont
lancé un deuxième vikings le frère du
premier qui va se poser ce soir à 21h52
non pas dans le désert mais près du pôle
nord de mars dans la plaine de l'utopie
à utopia planit re pour les amateurs de
latin imaginez un instant que vous soyez
sur mars près de la calotte polaire nord
et bien c'est là que vikings 2 va se
poser ce soir à 21h50 de bien sur l'eau
ne ruisselle rappaz comme ici mais les
scientifiques espèrent bien
trouvé dans le sous sol sous forme je
les ai bien sûr qui dit qu'au 10 vies
possibles victimes de le frère jumeau de
viking 1 a donc comme priorité la
recherche de la vie et le scénario sera
exactement le même d'abord il va y avoir
séparation de l'engin en deux parties
l'une va rester en orbite tandis que la
deuxième va plonger dans les couches
denses de l'atmosphère puis c'est le
freinage aérodynamique les parachutes
l'allumage des rétrofusées et enfin
l'atterrissage en douceur
ensuite eh bien on attend avec
impatience les premières photos du grand
nord martien et dans une semaine
débuteront les nouvelles analyses qui
peut être résoudrons l'énigme posée par
la vie martienne
après ça il faut quand même parler des
autres nouvelles pour l'important quand
même de l'agro venir sur terre avec la
d'abord la grève la sncf jean claude
narcy les grèves à la sncf ont affecté
sur tout le réseau de banlieue
parisienne moins de 50% des trains ont
pu circuler sur les grandes lignes le
trafic était plus perturbé que prévu
pour demain la direction générale de la
sncf a fait des prévisions alors pour la
banlieue paris montparnasse 30% vous
voyez sur votre écran 30% du service
assuré gare de lyon paris austerlitz et
saint lazare 40%
paris est et invalide 50% paris-nord 70%
et puis pour les grandes lignes et bien
le mieux est quand même de téléphoner
avant de vous rendre à la gare
monseigneur lefebvre n'a pas que des
adeptes chez les catholiques
traditionalistes pierre debray qui est
l'animateur des silencieux de l'église a
déclaré que son mouvement ne suivaient
pas monseigneur lefebvre et qu'il
n'était pas possible de remettre en
question l'autorité du pape
les britanniques sont accusés d'avoir
torturé des détenus en irlande du nord
en août 1971 sur plainte du gouvernement
irlandais la commission européenne des
droits de l'homme accusent le
gouvernement de londres donc d'avoir
autorisé le mauvais traitement par la
police et l'armée au cours
d'interrogatoires de prisonniers en
ulster dublin demande la condamnation
ces sévices ce qui a créé bien entendu
un malaise entre londres et dublin effet
bien la sphère des terroristes de l'ira
zurich en état de siège du monde à
zurich se prépare à la rencontre qui
signèrent vorster les conversations
entre le chef de la diplomatie
américaine et le premier ministre sud
africain ne seront pas facilitée par les
récentes déclarations d'henri kissinger
qui a vivement critiqué avant-hier la
politique d'apartheid du gouvernement
d'afrique du sud et je vous rappelle
ensuite quadrillé kissinger
s'entretiendra mardi prochain à paris
avec valéry giscard d'estaing vague de
mutineries dans plusieurs prisons
d'europe à turin après trois jours de
révolte laissant mutins se sont rendus
aux policiers qui ont dû donner l'assaut
en grande-bretagne même épilogue dans la
prison de hull les dégâts provoqués par
les prisonniers sont estimés à près d'un
milliard d'anciens francs et puis à
bruxelles aujourd'hui neuf détenus très
dangereux se sont évadés de la prison
centrale de forest et parmi eux deux
français
le salaire de la peur version vécu au
brésil un camion chargé d'une tonne et
demie de dynamite a explosé en plein
centre de la ville de curitiba
on compte plusieurs dizaines de morts
300 blessés des maisons ont été
littéralement pulvérisé les vitres des
immeubles brisées dans un rayon de plus
de deux kilomètres un cas de choléra a
signal à paris mais il faut pas
s'affoler le malade un marocain est en
observation à l'hôpital clown bertras
bernard parent dont le virus est
importée du maroc et les proches du
malade sont également en observation
mais c'est tout de même le premier cas
de choléra en france depuis 1973
encore une éruption de volcan mais cette
fois si près de manille talent l'un des
plus petits volcans du monde a émis des
vapeurs noir et projeté des cendres
cela plus de 2000 mètres de haut les
habitants comme en guadeloupe ont dû
évacuer la région ils se souviennent
qu'il n'ya pas si longtemps en 1965 une
éruption avait fait plus de 200 morts et
mort en 1961 en 1911 pardon incendies de
forêts en corse plus de 700 hectares de
maquis ont été ravagés dans la région de
nebbio les pompiers aidés des canadairs
ont maîtrisé le feu attisé toute la
journée par un fort mistral et puis un
autre foyer s'est déclaré en fin de
matinée à 25 km à l'ouest de bastia au
dessus du golfe de saint florent
si les agriculteurs ont des raisons de
se plaindre de la sécheresse et bien les
chasseurs vont en bénéficier car le
gibier c'est bien reproduit cette année
en particulier le gibier à poil c'est
surtout vrai dans le sud de la france où
l'ouverture a lieu dimanche dans 20
départements et cela concerne 500 mille
chasseurs une chance une fois
supplémentaire pour le gibier
la chasse sera suspendu 1 à 3 jours par
semaine
bon alors le temps pour pour la chasse
c'est pour les autres activités à ça
c'est quand même beaucoup rafraîchie en
quelques jours le ciel est resté
variable aujourd'hui avec des
températures plutôt fraîches
regardez par exemple 12 degrés besançon
mais tout de même 24 à nice aussi 20 sur
la corse seulement demain le temps
restera nuageux avec de belles périodes
ensoleillées de l'atlantique à la médina
la méditerranée où le mistral soufflera
quelques pluies attendues sur le nord
est et les ardennes le fond de l'air
sera très frais au lever du jour plus
clément dans la journée c'est à peu près
le type de temps qu'on aura aussi
dimanche
alors est-ce que c'est déjà l'hiver
chaque année c'est la même chose on vous
dit avec excès d'ailleurs que les
hirondelles ont vite filé ou que les
cigognes retourne à toute vitesse vers
les pays chauds et que s'annonce un
hiver précoce les signes avant coureurs
sont souvent démenties par la suite
alors quand les morts les marmottes
s'endorment tout de suite maintenant
alors vous pensez il n'y a plus qu'à
allumer le chauffage central eh bien oui
j'ai lu quelque part que les marmottes
du valais en suisse se sont enterrés
pour hiberner avec un mois d'avancé
voici les marmottes et vous le voyez le
sont encore gaillarde
elles ont été filmées cet été d'ailleurs
elles sont bien grasse poil luisant un
certain sourire vous n'avez peut-être
pas vu mais je les ai vus mois un
certain sourire
elles sont bien nourris
et justement les spécialistes des
marmottes pense que si elle commence à
hiberner maintenant c'est parce qu'elles
ont trop manger cet été est qu'elles
veulent tout de suite se mettre au
régime
c'est un peu ce que nous devrions faire
et puis nous devrions aussi considéré
comme une troupe de marmottes ne fait
pas l'hiver la chasse à la marmotte
c'est bien de cette façon là pour la
bonne soirée à tous au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité le prochain
journal
à 22h50 merci